I'm a medical secretary in a medical office.
We answer the phone, greet patients, pull charts and files, answer any questions...
...and schedule appointments.
You not only get to work with people, you also get to meet new people each and every day.
That's my favorite part of the job.
I did go back and get a two-year degree at a local college,...
...but majority of it is on-the-job training.
We work a normal business day from 8 to 5.
I particularly like the hours and sometimes we get Fridays off, so I really like that.
The salary range, I would say, would be based on your experience.
The money's good.
My favorite part about my job is probably just meeting different people each day.
My favorite part about my job is being involved with the people.